you
hi everyone it's Jerry i'ma and chess
comm and I'm going to play a 15-2 game
against the Beast it's been some time
since I played against computer
impossible
alright oh I was just trying to say he
has a here's a low rating I'm not used
to seeing sub 2000 from computer for
possible also this is a bit of a
surprise b6 okay well I play Eve for
right away I could do that thinking more
d4 hmm let's go with d4 I'm hesitant to
play e4 because I don't want to play
Knight c3 I want to keep open the option
of moving my C pond and after E for
Bishop b7 it's a bit awkward to defend
efore and I don't want to play d3 so I'm
thinking of pretty normal ish moves here
Bishop f4 comes to mind hmm if I play c4
there's gonna be six and then we're very
close to this being a like a Queen's
Indian I want I want to maybe rule out
some idea of Bishop b4 pinning my knight
or landing a check and so I'm thinking
of keeping my C pawn back in order to
combat some Bishop b4 ideas so having
said this I think I'm leaning more
towards Bishop f4 III and declaring my
LightSquared Bishop sin tension prior to
moving my C pawn or queen Knight and a
gun for that
all righty then on III is this night
looking to hunt down my bishop I may
want to invest a tempo in h3 just to
preserve my dark square bishop hmm I
wonder if there's this potential to take
my night I don't think that that could
really be bad for me on h3 Bishop takes
Knight it's a little bit of a weird
structure I guess I would take with the
epon in that case yeah I'd be fine with
that I think something I have to be on
the lookout for is Knight d5 striking at
my bishop but there's it's really not
hitting at anything else
III Knight h5 yeah I really don't know
if I want to allow computer to hunt down
my dark square bishop let me let me
address this tempo and see if it grabs
my knight now all right so let's get in
this standard move III now that I have a
square in h2 maybe Bishop d6 no I don't
know my first impression with this is
that I'm happy I don't have to worry
about there see pawns striking at my
Center so having said that this gives my
bishop a little bit more direction
because if I played a d3 Knight be four
strikes at my bishop and then allow c5
so of these two squares I'm thinking
leaning more towards e2 or maybe I
should commit my knight my queen Knight
to d2 and then think about c3 which
rules out a night before and then Bishop
d3 clearly investing some time here I
want to see
well I'm trying to work out what I feel
would be the best arrangement for my
minor pieces and in what order should I
play these moves I think I quite like
this idea of night 2d - Bishop before is
no concern I immediately control eform
and then I can look forward to see three
Bishop d3 uh yeah let's go for that I'll
commit my knight right away okay so
where would black spawn break is pawn
break be trying to anticipate some moves
down the line where will black create
pawn tension in a break for their rooks
to then come to life I have a plan in
that of c3 Bishop d3 and then expanding
in the center let's see anything wrong
with this idea yeah let's get this
move in c3 Bishop d3 for the moment the
bishop is unprotected if C 3 d6 Bishop
d3 maybe e5 as an idea maybe I could
take like a a move out by playing Bishop
to h2 computer probably just Castle
after I play c3 let's go and see c3
right right now okay so a Bishop d2
Queen e2 pretty standard moves castles
the way I view this is that if I could
control this Knight
I am controlling their Bishop I don't
really have much worry of their Bishop
alright let's swing the back completely
around here this was my idea
much more aggressive post okay I guess
f5 is the idea two squares to consider
here g3 or h2 I may want to go to h2
because I don't know if I want to run
into f4 advances with some strike
against my Bishop I may want to meet an
f4 move with e4 hmm let's go up it back
to h2 I think he's a bit more secure
there okay I guess Queen e2 maybe i
should remain flexible here with my king
yeah maybe mm-hmm
excuse me maybe there's an idea of
castling queenside and then taking
advantage of this f5 advance with g4
yeah I'm gonna retain some flexibility
with my king I like this Queen e2 move I
think she knows her place yeah this
isn't good for black that's not to say
I'm gonna be able to take advantage of
this but this is very awkward
although hmm clearly what's being lined
up here is a c5 break otherwise this is
just ridiculous
closed filed a closed file type move c5
is being lined up so
where's this night headed I guess he's
looking in looking to go to a five and
then see five my king will be on the C
file huh I don't know if I played g4
black was isn't going to take because
that would give me play against the H
file the h7 pond hmm could I get away
with leaving the King in the center rook
G 1 and G 4 is that to cave mannish you
only live once right we're gonna see I
like seeing that move hey 5 I don't have
to worry about Knight a5 4 1 and I
wonder if I should invest a tempo with a
for stopping any space gaining moves
with black playing a form or should I
just get on with G form mm-hmm I kind of
like taking a time out to play a for
myself I think my king will be secure
here
all right let's let's carry on with that
g4 it is whoa come on now take with the
rook keep this G file open yeah I don't
want to take with the pawn and you take
with the rook here and I up sacrifices
on this square all of a sudden how to
say this looks really really appealing
all right let's grab that poem keep the
G file open and now we're to go with my
rook ideally I'd like to keep the G 1
square open to eventually double but if
I go to G 3 there's a knight here if I
go to G - it's in the bishops view
mm-hmm I think I'm actually quite all
right if I go to G 2 I don't think that
this is such an annoying pin or anything
let's go to G 2 I like my position I
must say yeah computers floundering here
I'm not sure maybe it's having an off
day he Knight f6 Rick G rook g2 and then
Knight back to d5 yeah maybe it's having
an off day I'm just looking to castle
double rooks and then smash through on
g6 I was black surviving there playing
without their Bishop rook Queen Knight
and I'm just I have a lot of pieces here
towards their king
this must be winning I really feel like
this must be already winning
well can I already sacrifice here
honestly I don't see what the rush it
would be with even doing that let's just
add one more piece to the to the attack
here yeah let's do it yeah running
scared alright this is the only half
opened file in the position for white
let's get there
alrighty now how to win I have to be
careful of this as mentioned I don't
wanna be so quick to allow this Knight
to move and let this bishop come to life
what is the way forward here should I
already do a piece AK is Knight here an
idea hmm efore a5
I could play e4 and then get this move
in I weakened f4 but I think I want to
kick this night away and then just smash
through on g6 because then computer
can't even contest my rook on this
square so II 45 and then sacrifice on g6
move my knight and then get here this
won't be a secure square anymore if a 45
Knight h5 and I take twice here I have
this night lined up Wow
yeah I think I like efore efore 9h v e5
Knight f4 take I'm gonna take here my
bishop I might be able to take already
with the bishop on this square can I do
without e4 I'm at four minutes let's see
Bishop takes pawn takes rook takes
threatening rook here
mm-hmm maybe get my bishop in a
different spot now let me see Bishop
takes pawn takes rook takes hmm
I'm up this night he isn't playing yet
should I get him involved
hmm h4 h5 I gotta go at something if I
play e4 maybe d6 happens but then I have
Knight here hitting that pond let's
let's do it it's been way too too much
time on that okay that make that let's
this square is now weakened hmm play
Knight g5 let's see hmm
Knight h4 and then sacrifice here that
seems crushing isn't it let's let's
smash throughout g6 my Knights
unprotected mmhmm yeah but still but
still I don't think I should take right
away let's let's invite another piece
towards the Kings side okay I could take
here whenever Queen here maybe to defend
No
okay Knight here there's Knight f7 stuff
I think now I should maybe sacrifice or
maybe consider a 5 hmm 2 minutes my
goodness
maybe d5 pawn takes and then here just
to make sure this Bishop isn't seeing my
rook d5 pawn takes e5 Knight takes d5
takes push-on takes Knight takes Bishop
takes and then I'm looking at sacrifices
here there knight is pinned mmm
close to something good here so close to
losing as well in time it's tough man it
is tough Knight g5 maybe f4 and then e 5
let's do that see what you got
push d 5 anchor knight in here it's
thinking whew okay so I could get this
check in let's get f4 in first mm-hmm
okay and I think I just want to play
here without losing some material I can
grab this pawn hmm should I really be
worried of that let's just make a
defensive move for a moment right there
all right
I haven't no I don't have a knight check
let's go here hmm all right I could push
here no quite actually pushing here yeah
there's some issue on this square let's
get this move in really sharp now really
sharp take here pawn takes I take the
knight rook takes 37 seconds oh my
goodness I just dropped my queen oh man
oh wow that was a really bad blunder let
me hit that resigned button I can't
believe I just did that Wow I'm stunned
oh my goodness that is really bad
hmm I did not even see that my Queen was
hanging ouch I know I had something
there I just I wonder I wonder what the
winning
sequence was it's got to be winning
because of all the attacking pieces that
I have I'm gonna look at it with the
computer but before I even stare at it I
just want to know how I could have
smashed through efore maybe I should
just already go for this hmm
I mean I was pointing out on e4 and they
could play d6 and then if I'm doing this
mmm there's some captures I don't want
to allow this Knight to move I should
keep this dog and I'll open suppose I
went for this he got rook here there is
a knight block though computers a very
good defender of course
seems like this maybe Rick g8 mm-hmm and
Knight 2h7
I don't know if I'm really winning with
that sacrifice right away but right
around here I felt like there must be
something I mean the Knights running in
Reverse mm-hmm of course now I'm going a
bit defensive here with Bishop c2 and
then this rook to have to move yeah I
want to get this move in Wow yeah with
this move sequence right here where I
ended up blundering 4 pieces were
cleared out and I was just completely
blind to this rook my goodness
that was a shock and a half I don't know
what I should have done better here
perfectly honest I know I'm in a
superior position but how exactly to
convert it against the Beast hmm is e4
really the idea I go here Knight takes
bishop takes on dropping the rook
as mentioned earlier I mean if I'm on
the g3 square I have to look out for
Knight h5 stuff hmm man I don't know I'm
not sure how what I could have done
better the computer will certainly point
this out
maybe I should already dive in and
consult with stockfish at this point and
see where I could have converted this I
really do feel like this is a an
overwhelming attack I must have
something maybe even I castled here yeah
I mean I could think about sacrificing
right now with Chuck maybe instead of
queenside castle could I have already
done something like this while the king
is still on the G file and if he's going
over here this kind of stuff
maybe all right well we're gonna find
out just give me a second here and I'll
bring up stockfish seven okay stockfish
show me what I could have done better
this will be pretty even for the first I
guess 10 or so moves I've been feeling
that this is going to be painful to go
over there's there's must be some missed
opportunities
so let's see it already likes me
well nothing significant have five Queen
e2 points out e4 nothing wrong with
Queen e2 though I mean there's already
so much development in at this stage
it's it's just it's a secure square for
the Queen in as meant and mentioned
earlier it retains flexibility with my
king's residence rook c8 g4 is popping
up right now
nothing wrong with rook g1 okay yeah I
mean these are these are like passing
moves I must say like I have enough
experience playing against the computer
different computers and this is just a
nothing move well if it was a nothing
move why am i replying with a four
shouldn't I just get on with this I
really couldn't have had anticipated a
an attack later on against my a for pawn
should I have I don't know like if I
want to eventually Castle if I'm playing
a four and I Castle queenside it is
unprotected but I really didn't have the
foresight to see that eventually the
Queen would be pinpointing a 4 mm it
wants to go straight in 4G form I mean
my concern was I don't know a 4 and then
I'm having to play a 3 I thought because
what I would not want to have happen is
let's just say I queenside castle on a 4
I think I need to do something about
this pawn now it's pointing out night b1
like because I don't want to allow a 3
like if I'm playing this look at a 3 is
now very strong with the idea of
crashing through on c3 undermining my
base point so I figured before I even
have to commit my a pawn to a3 let's
just stop that pawn cold
additionally by not allowing a 4 I don't
have to worry this is another thought
that ran through my mind I wasn't able
to voice it during the game but I didn't
want this well I said I didn't want this
night to move because then I have to be
concerned some about their Bishop well
if he is to move I don't want him to
move forward and if a 4 is played this
night could then move he's on a
five its forward and maybe c4 is a move
later on
I don't think anything could be so wrong
with a four not the not the best but
what is it it wants to go straight in
for g4 mm-hmm you know here's another
way to look at it I mean what happened
in the game g6 was played actually no
they cut a computer captured on g4 I was
thinking for a moment this was what
happened and you know if I get g4 in
right now while the king is still on the
G file they weren't able to recapture
like that but that's not what happened
in the game when I played g4 computer
took on g4 so I guess I could go
straight in for this takes takes Knight
f6 and it wants to go all the way back
with the rook hmm okay and I guess the
main reason for that is because it's
really too vulnerable to the minor
pieces g3 to the vulnerable to the
knight g2 vulnerable to the bishop all
the way back okay let's see if it says
similar after I insert a four and then
get castled okay I played g4 first chop
chop
Knight f6 wants to go rook g1 g2 doesn't
like that hmm that's tough too
I had her on I mean I guess part of my
problem here was hmm I would maybe like
to get this Bishop contributing to
attacking the king like if I could post
up on e5 I know I free the bishop on
Knight takes there's Bishop takes his
Bishop could see but also it brings my
bishop to life it just seemed more
natural to play to g2 does it not like
what would you what would you do in this
position I mean because I'm looking to
get all my pieces working but I guess
there's just some tactical issues I
wanted to keep g1 open for my Queen rook
I likes rook g1 though instead of rook
g2 g1 Bishop d6 and now Knight to e5 so
it really does want to post up there
suppose Bishop takes D takes aha now oh
now I really am crashing through on g6
like Knight here now this is well I
could just take the knight right away
mm-hmm so computer would probably have
to invest some time very soon
with playing King 2h 895 he wants to
play King h8 and then queenside castle
mm-hmm where was my biggest fault III
wonder if it was this infatuation with
not wanting C I didn't want to allow
black to unmask their light square
bishop but really in a way what what
dangers this light square bishop really
posing me you know it's it's staring off
into a diagonal now with dropping the
rip back to G 1 instead of G 2 it's
really not that big of a factor it's not
difficult to work around and it's not
like my king is Castle down the Kings
side so maybe and this was my this was
really the main adjustment with my
thinking during the game
hmm okay this is interesting maybe seven
King be one bishop see - you know it's a
pawn plus advantage let's get some more
moves in see how played out still likes
white now I'm doubling oh man I knew it
was going to be paying for +2 Knight f6
and now I should just sack I guess I
could just sacrifice here what I do I
play d4 it's still good but I should
just go straight in for this oh my god
oh it's painful man it's painful Knight
h7 95 and I'm just drifting over here
with my pieces who cares about this
Bishop this really had me I was too
fixated on this Bishop coming to life
but that's the only piece they would
have like I was saying earlier the rook
and the Queen weren't playing who cares
if this bishop is staring at H 1 G 2 F 3
they're not it's of no bother and my
queen coming out to h5 this is another
way to look at it if I can't move my
knight from f3 to a good square how does
my Queen enter the attack maybe that's
another correction I could be making I
mean I'm looking to attack the King I'm
looking to basically checkmate like this
isn't some I'm looking for some
positional win we're opposite sides
Castle I should be looking for the
king's throw I need my Queens help how
can I have better brought her to life I
need to move my knight if it's if it
happens to be the case that this Bishop
is brought to life by freeing up my
queen so be it but I need to get my
Queen into the attack mmm
+5 as you're sitting here ah man
Bishop e5 it likes Knight takes Knight
takes Queen coming out to h5 maybe
Knight f7
and even there's a mate threat suppose
this there's rook she ate all these
mating ideas are now right around the
corner ah man yeah I had a feeling it
was going to be painful reviewing this
one I should just sacrifice here I
played Eve for silly unnecessary to kick
this night away I should have just
smashed thrown g6 and then just kind of
assess it as I have plenty plenty more
aggressive pieces plenty more attackers
than they have defenders on the Kings
side and they still have these out of
play pieces over here on the Queen side
man ok I played efore it's still winning
B 5 I should be playing let's have a
look at one more winning idea takes
takes Knight takes e5 Bishop takes
giving up the rook and I kind of wanted
to avoid something like this giving up
any material Bishop d6 Knight f4 yeah
this is a little bit a little bit more
complicated of a line instead of the one
where I'm immediately sacrificing on g6
but wow yeah I have really all pieces
attacking at this stage Queen e7 Bishop
c4 it's a little bit awkward coming off
of that diagonal but I guess many
different ways to win from there easy
for the computer but clearly enough for
me and this one still likes me Knight g5
and then Knight takes h7 yeah it's still
winning when is it not winning as soon
as I retreated and went defensive Knight
takes h7 King take
rook takes man ah didn't even consider
Knight takes h7 that was another winning
idea likes me only by a hair well not
anymore
+3 ish with E 5 suppose takes the knight
takes g6 Bishop takes oh man I could
have been looking more at g7 or h7 and
g6 hmm
what other correction should I have made
with my can I make with my thinking here
I think I was too gun-shy with investing
some material for an attack and maybe a
little bit too much still on the
positional side when I certainly should
not be in these opposite sides castling
situations mm-hmm should have certainly
looked into the more direct stuff
investing some material to get the King
get at the King and then this blunder at
the end
ouch that's rough I don't even see it at
this point I was thinking on my next
move if they're not careful I take the
knight yeah mmm painful and had a good
position clearly and yeah I like this
idea certainly would do it again with
rook to G 1 and G 4 I'm not committed my
king just yet and this is not a good
this is not a good setup
you know over to c8 and I don't see 6
there's a couple things that need to
happen before this file is even open and
I have an overwhelming attack that I
clearly did not convert okay well I hope
there was still something to take away
from this one even though there was that
blunder like that losing my queen
anyhow feel free to leave any feedback
to this video in the
comment section below as usual and I
hope you got something out of it that's
all for now take care bye
you